qu'est ce que tu dirais aux gens parce
qu'il ya plein de gens aussi qui dise
comment on fait les couches et nous on a
envie de la viande
qu'es-tu leurs directs moi je dirais
alors moi j'ai arrêté parce que j'ai
fait des beaucoup de reportages et
enquêtes dans les abattoirs les élevages
industriels sur la pêche industrielle et
j'ai découvert des informations que je
connaissais pas moi je mangeais beaucoup
de viande beaucoup de poissons mon père
est un pécheur sous-marin qui faisait
beaucoup beaucoup de pêche sous-marine
donc j'ai toujours mangé beaucoup
d'animaux je m'étais jamais posé la
question et je me moquais des
végétariens un peuple est en fait en
faisant ses enquêtes dans le monde de
l'élevage industriel de me suis rendu
compte de tout ce qu'on nous cachait que
99% par exemple des porcs élevés en
france sont élevés dans un bâtiment
enfermées toute leur vie avec 1%
d'élevage en plein air les poules
pondeuses ses 63 % des le bassin
d'élevage en cage les lapins c'est 100%
d'élevage en cage et en fait ces
chiffres là ça nous montre qu'on peut
pas échapper à l'élevage industriel
si on mange de la viande régulièrement
donc moi j'ai décidé d'arrêter parce que
je me voyais pas continuer à participer
mais si les gens déjà réduise ses supers
moi j'encourage tout le monde à faire à
son rythme je suis pas du tout en train
de dire tout le monde sait
qu'aujourd'hui il est politiquement ils
sont un petit peu agressif on voit la
sueur sociable à ses 5000 euros et je
pense qu'il y ait plus de l'agressivité
plus les gens dits de bâle où c'est quoi
ils sont venus nombreux à ce qu'ils nous
font chier
il ya plein de l'église une fonction d
vegan est il nécessaire la cote des
actions qui sont trop durs jl-c on ne
culpabilise un peu quand on mange de la
viande mais moi ce que j'aime bien dans
votre discours justement c'est qu'il
n'est pas prosélyte et vous forcez pas
les gens à arrêter de soi par exemple
c'est vrai que ça fait prendre
conscience j'avais lu votre livre quand
il était sorti et par exemple j'ai
découvert le quinoa j'en mangeais pas
beaucoup mais je mange maintenant des
boîtes et des boîtes et les boîtes de
quinoa le midi et le soir les bleus fut
pas malgré tout et ça des vitamines et
ça demain tu as regardé quoi
et un chinois seront importants je
pensais que les gens et les informations
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ce n'est pas
rien c'est un livre dans quête
d'informations après chacun décide en
conscience mais ce qui est important
c'est de savoir de quoi on parle et
qu'on puisse débattre avec des
informations fiables